hey bobo you're on the air in Florida
how you doing there Howard I think after
you kick Fred out of the band this
inspires him to write a song titled
Russia I don't know if you saw it on his
Instagram yeah I felt bad a lot of
people afterwards said you know Fred
really feels bad that you kicked him out
of the band now he's producing no not I
don't feel bad at all and uh
congratulations on Turkish and uh thank
you thank you you know what it is
although I type in took it so it comes
out 2-2 so you might want to change the
name of that band no no no don't worry
about it Fred we don't need your help I
want to go with the rage against the
bidet or Earth Wind and feces you sound
good Fred what did you do like you got
upset and you you said Okay a long time
ago and I guess there was a lot of [__]
going on a lot of people getting even
more killed than before than Ukraine and
I don't understand why anybody would be
against us supporting the Ukraine in
their efforts to try and get rid of
Russia but uh it's just something that I
felt and I threw
Fred's song called Russia no it's not
called Russia it's called just stop
somewhere
so stop somewhere oh that's cool
[Music]
let me help this song out
you need me
maybe somebody's brother that you cannot
recognize safe Fred's good so he doesn't
need me he doesn't need to be in our
bank
s we said now want to record this song
what is that Robin
he just got selective Amnesia now here's
this thing with Fred's songs
Fred's a really good songwriter but I'm
not you know he should record his songs
in other words uh he didn't need me
although I did this weekend I was very
busy I actually wrote a song with Robin
in mind
and uh I might start a band with Robin
you know what nothing would please me
more
so I might send you the song Robin I I
put together we put together a demo you
sent me a song no this is this is a
different song entirely song entirely
doesn't really let me tell you something
great singing nothing nothing
for me nothing lights a fire under
Fred's ass like throwing them out of the
band look at this guy now he can't stop
right prolific but I think I actually
have a hit song with this one so I'll
send it your way Robin you tell me what
you think very nice all right the hit
song Howard what happened yeah but he
inspired the hit song so you know
you first get a hit song Rob and then
we'll worry about what happened all
right